c'était à moscou ce week-end devant un
des hôpitaux dédié à la comique 19 une
file interminable d'ambulance dans
chacune se trouve un patient soupçonnées
d'être infectées
ces images sont belles et bien vrai ont
confirmé les autorités au cas où
certains doutent encore le nombre
d'hospitalisations a doublé depuis
dimanche on en compte désormais 1300 par
jour a concédé la numéro deux de la
mairie de masquer des cheats leur saute
sur la ville
liège son chien on ne voit presque plus
prise d'un poutine qui de toute évidence
avait tort de dire que la russie serait
épargné dans son bureau complètement
isolé il a prévenu les gouverneurs que
toute gestion tardive sera traitée comme
la négligence criminelle car c'était une
catastrophe annonce ça fait des semaines
qu'on prévient les autorités locales
d'une vague sans précédent de fièvre et
de pneumonies explique la docteure rimac
à malo va que nous avons joint par skype
à oufa à 1200 km de moscou
mais on nous a interdit testé pour la
cause l'idée de faire le diagnostic dit
elle signait son hôpital est aujourd'hui
un des plus importants foyers d'éclosion
aux pays plus 500 employés et autant
patient et sont enfermés près de 200 ont
testé positif elle attend le résultat de
son propre test sa fièvre persiste mais
elle doit continuer de soigner dans les
circonstances
nous avons perdu trois semaines
déplore-t-elle
c'est seulement nous avait écoutés
d'autres médecins des sonné l'alarmé y
compris le docteur alex cia koblet il
nous a ouvert les portes de son hôpital
privé où plus de 200 patients sont
hospitalisés pour des pneumonies virales
shirt
traitons tous comme des infections
coronavirus d'ici c'est d'ailleurs la
nouvelle directive de la santé publique
en russie qui ne sera pas plus seulement
sur les tests en laboratoire
puisqu'ils ne sont pas fiables il est de
plus en plus difficile de ce qu'il ya
statistiques officielles mais ce qui se
passe sur la ligne de front ne ment pas
comme en témoigne ce médecin en
quarantaine dans son hôpital de province
restez à la maison je vous en supplie
protéger nous aussi pour que je puisse
revoir ma fille et la serrer dans mes
bras
un message à ceux qui continuent de
circuler même pour aller à la messe
moscou qui selon les épidémiologistes se
dirige tout droit vers un scénario à la
new yorkaise sera plus que jamais isolé
dès demain seuls les automobilistes qui
ont un laissez-passer auront le droit de
sortir de la capitale
une mesure extraordinaire pour limiter
les dégâts dans le reste du pays
ici tu as marre alter escaut radio
canada montréal